it's a great pleasure today to be
speaking with jeffrey west who's a
theoretical physicist and professor at
the santa fe institute
uh one of his uh great
books which i recently read is scale the
universal laws of growth innovation
sustainability and the pace of life
in organisms cities economies and
companies uh professor west it's so
great having you on
hey david thank you for inviting me
pleasure to be home so
i want to start with something very
basic just to kind of get the audience
acquainted with with the subject matter
of the book when we talk about scale
in life
we can apply this to
the human body we can apply this
across species we can look at businesses
cities etc as you do
how did you first come into being
interested in this concept of scale in
life
well i think really it originates you
know i'm a theoretical physicist in
terms of my training and my career uh
dealing with fundamental questions in
physics you know quarks and gluons and
string theory and evolution of the
universe etc um you know those big
questions but in that
a major theme
in that and in fact across physics and
all engineering and technology is the
question of scale how do you scale up
what happens if you scale up a body if
you scale up a building um if you scale
up the universe uh you know what you
know these some of these might be
hypothetical questions uh but some of
them are uh you know very seriously
practical questions that we have to face
in society so so i got interested from
fundamental physics but uh realizing um
and that was sort of the the thing later
in my career that this had implications
just as you said across the entire
spectrum of the world around us
in the book you give examples of aspects
of life
that scale linearly sublinearly or super
linearly and this gives rise to certain
efficiencies and inefficiencies that we
can identify
a number we couldn't possibly talk about
every interesting anecdote that you
include in the book but again to give
the audience some idea of what we're
talking about could you give us one
example of each of these three phenomena
in life that can be observed
sure yes so the simplest is linear
linear simply means if i double the size
of the system
i get something twice as big that's
simply so for example
if you double the size of a city not
surprisingly
you sort of get twice as many
dwellings let's call it that way twice
as many houses because each person so to
speak needs a place to live so that's
linear so that's not surprising
but um
the
sub linear what we call sublinear is
when if you double the size you don't
get twice as much but you get less than
twice as much so for example
to take a different system
at mammals we're a mammal and we go from
a shroom to a mouse
to us to elephants and blue whales and
what is amazing is if you look at any
quantity that describes them any
physiological variable like the number
of heartbeats the length of the aorta
how long they live these scale in a very
regular systematic way and one of the
most fundamental quantities is metabolic
rate how much food you need each day to
stay alive and if you've doubled the
size of an organism or you looked at one
that's twice the size of another you
might have naively expected well you
need twice as much food you have twice
as many cells no you actually need
roughly speaking three-quarters as much
you save 25
with each saving that's called
sub-linear scaling and is a
manifestation of a systematic economy of
scale so before you give us an example
of super linear yeah
to think about that example
you could in a sense have a an
individual that weighs twice as much as
another they don't need twice the food
they only need 75 percent more it's more
efficient on a per pound basis in that
sense yes there's so well
what i would like to talk about here is
less about those within species than a
cross
species scaling we can also discuss
scaling within it's slightly different
sure but if you just look at just across
species or across different mammals then
there's this saving so put slightly
differently um each cell in your body
if you double the size actually requires
less energy the bigger you are and by
the way
that feeds into why it is that bigger
animals live much longer than uh smaller
ones because they're using less energy
to support the same gram of tissue or
the same cell
so it's a systematic economy of scale
and by the way we see that in our cities
it's the same thing in terms of our
infrastructure you double the size of a
city i said you need twice as many
houses but you only need about 85
percent as many roads or 85 percent as
much electrical lines so it's quite
similar to biology except the saving is
sort of 15
with each doubling rather than 25 but
it's again an economy of scale sublinear
scaling
now an example of of super linear
scaling
yeah so super linear scaling is quite
fascinating because it's really does not
occur in the natural biosphere
it's almost all sublinear scaling and
the biosphere is incredibly efficient
it's uh this economy of scale permeates
on the other hand but social systems
socioeconomic systems have the opposite
behavior and that comes about because
socioeconomic
systems are driven by social networks
interaction between people like you and
i are doing and we build on each other
in terms of the conversation and that
means the bigger you are so i mean the
less
per capita so to speak you have the more
per capita so the example would be for
example if you ask how many patents how
many ideas are created in a city and
look at it as a function of the size of
a city so again totally naively if you
double the size of the city that means
you have twice as many people well you
might get twice as many patents no
you actually get
another 15 added every time you double
so the bigger the city the more ideas
are created and that's because there are
more social interactions and so on
and the more of all social economic
activity the higher the wages per capita
and so on and so forth so we would
expect
we would expect that in a one million
person city
there would be more patents than in the
sum total of ten hundred thousand person
cities exactly that's a very nice way of
saying it and the way we often say it is
like that i think that's it's a very
powerful way of saying you you gain
tremendously by bringing people together
rather than divvying them up
into groups subgroups which act
autonomously and of course you gain
something very big i mean that's nothing
to do with quality of life for example
but in terms of sort of material
kinds of metrics
bigger is better
in the book a fascinating um example of
this that you give
is you compare for example a very very
small animal like a mouse
to an elephant and you say well the
elephant lives a lot longer in terms of
time
the elephant also has a much slower
heartbeat and so over the course of the
life of a mouse and an elephant even
though the elephant is here for many
more years its heart beats more slowly
and both the mouse and the elephant
would have roughly the same number of
heartbeats per lifetime
that that's quite fascinating
what is the underlying principle that is
guiding that
yes no it is it's quite fascinating that
the number of heartbeats in a lifespan
if you look across all mammals from the
smallest to the largest is roughly the
same about one and a half billion and um
and what is underlying that and all of
the scaling laws is networks it's the
fact that all these things are
controlled by networks and all the work
that i did
was in terms of
uh deriving
the
the concepts and the mathematics
uh that uh
show you where these scaling laws come
from and in particular where this
scaling law this invariant so to speak
this
this constancy of heartbeats comes from
and indeed just let me just go back to
something i said earlier uh just to give
you a sense of that
is that um
the
uh i said that the bigger you are
the the the less energy needed per cell
to stay alive so your
your cells are working um less hard than
your cats or dogs but they're working
harder than your elephants
so to speak and so the bigger you are
the less hard the cells work therefore
less damage is done within the cell and
in transporting energy and information
through these networks
therefore you can live longer because
you're doing less damage so that's sort
of the the the the the sort of simple
idea behind it you live longer if you're
bigger because you do less damage
transporting energy information and
resources to the cells to keep you alive
and so that causes the decrease and the
and in fact all
rates
basically
slow down the bigger you are in a
systematic way so that if you look
through the right lens
it's not just that life lifespans are
the same so to speak that is you should
measure them by heartbeats but your
growth rates and everything else
is sort of the same if you you they all
rescale to look quite similar if you
rescale accordingly so it brings up sort
of a speculative question even though
a mouse lives two years
and a whale is 125 years maybe in a
certain sense experientially it's the
same
right processes have rescaled
appropriately yeah this is often brought
up when people talk about their dogs
quite frankly where they say
we experience the dog's life as being
relatively short compared to ours
but if we account for all of these
systems you're talking about the dog may
experience a life that to it feels just
as long as ours we just don't know
we don't know of course as i said it's
speculative yeah by the way i want to
add one major caveat to that yeah
we are one of those mammals and indeed
if you look at us as sort of
biologically biologically meaning when
we were hunter-gatherers before we
discovered language
social networks
innovation and created all the marvelous
things that we do now
when we were purely biological we fit
perfectly on all these scaling cards we
had the right metabolic rate
we lived
30 or 40 years now some of your
listeners may have already realized that
one and a half billion heartbeats
corresponds for a human being to about
uh 30 or 40 years which of course was
the lifespan
of human beings
on the average until
maybe only 100 years ago you know you my
great-great-grandfather
his life expectancy was about 45 and
that was typical in in i come from
england in the united kingdom but it's
also typical in the united states so
then we violated that so we have
completely violated the scaling law in
terms of our metabolism we now even
though biologically we only use 2 000
food calories a day but in fact the
amount of energy we need to have this
kind of standard and quality of life is
more like 100 times that so all of our
metrics get distorted and we've
separated ourselves from the this
marvelous unity
and integration of nature
let's let's dig into exactly that topic
because there's so many different
aspects of what you talk about that that
are relevant to this idea of human
longevity
first i guess to kind of establish a
level playing field
is it not true that even when the
average life expectancy at birth was 40
or 45 that that was significantly
influenced by high infant mortality and
that if one made it to say age 20 their
odds of becoming much older are were
actually quite similar to what they are
today is is that not a factor
yeah it's roughly true um it's still
nevertheless true that uh so let me give
you some statistics in about 1830 the
lifespan of a human being on the planet
was about 35 maybe
in
what became developed countries that
number was more like 45 40 early 40s
but it increased if you took out infant
mortality if you just remove those that
died before age one because in the
natural state you know we're supposed to
have you know 10 to 12 children and
three or four supposed to die i hate to
put it so crassly um
and um and so if you take out those that
died in in infancy the number does
increase to 40 45 and then but then just
as you say if you make it
beyond um i forget the age exactly but
if you make it sort of age 10 12 and so
on into three or teens uh your
likelihood of reaching 60 is now
not as high as it is now that's for sure
but is already significantly increased
and indeed people did live i mean there
were we obviously know historically
people who live to 60 80 even 100
obviously but they were outliers and um
a long tail in the distribution of ages
so and the the biggest change by the way
that took place in increasing longevity
took place in the 19th century
with the uh introduction of um access to
clean water right and
hygiene hygiene and sewer putting in
sewers and so on had has had the biggest
increase in our longevity because up to
then uh the overwhelming majority of
people did not wash themselves obviously
didn't have access to hygiene
so a lot of the data that you present in
your book
uh points to this idea
of a kind of natural
limit on the human lifespan 100 110 120
in ideal circumstances avoiding disease
etc
and this is a great subject of focus for
those who are working on on human
longevity um
many of whom i've interviewed and when i
present them with this sort of natural
limit that you talk about they have very
different answers in different cases
there are some who focus on this issue
of cellular damage and finding
technological ways to fix the cellular
damage so to speak
there are others who focus in on
the combination of
humans with technology to create
something that is maybe going to
ultimately be beyond human in order to
change that
when you think about human longevity in
the future are you more on the side of
this is close to the natural limit
or more to there are solutions but they
might be quite drastic or where where is
your mind on this issue yeah so i i let
me pre let me just say a little preamble
to that yeah indeed this whole question
of longevity and mortality
is obviously fascinating we're all
fascinated by it uh because it is us and
uh
and it's the as i said as i often say
it's the second most important uh event
in your life the first big birth
so it and and it's surprising how lit
until recently how little
um energy and research was devoted to it
it's that's one of them it's an
interesting subject of itself
but um uh so and it was this fascination
that got me involved in all of this work
and all of the work i described in the
book from biology through cities to
companies and so on it was this question
of aging and mortality so in answer to
your question i
well let me say one of the the the quest
that i put myself on was
what if just as you say if you if you
can avoid disease avoid having an
accident
etc etc how long could you conceivably
live or to put it slightly differently
why in the hell do i age in the first
place
and uh that was that's what started me
on this and i believe i've answered that
and the answer is is very simple in a
certain sense uh and that is of course
the very system that's keeping you alive
this flow of energy and resources
through your networks blood through your
cardiovascular system and so on is
keeping you alive but it's also
destroying you because it creates wear
and tear on the system it does damage
and just as you say you have to repair
that and we do repair it but we only we
can't we don't spend all of our
resources repairing ourselves because
we'd be couch potatoes we allocate a
certain amount to it
so that we can do all the rest of things
in in our lives
and
we allocate enough so as to reap
live long enough to reproduce the not
children so our genes pass on
so
i've done
because i've created this network theory
for understanding these scaling laws
um there's a theory from which you can
calculate this amount of damage and you
can ask um
you can ask
uh how much um
how long could it take before a certain
amount of damage is done that the system
is no longer viable and you can
calculate that and you can understand
why we live of the order of 100 years
because that's a fundamental question
where in the hell does 100 years come
from for us whereas the same genes and
the same kind of physiology leads to two
years if you're a mouse now why is that
so that's what this explains and so on
so
you so i feel quite strongly that
talking about
how you can extend longevity
or what determines longevity you first
have to understand
why it is we age and what sets the scale
of 100 years and then you can ask what
are the parameters and how can i tune
them what do i do to fiddle with them
and so on and that's what all of the
present work of course on life extension
isabel
so i would say
that um
if you do want to extend by the way that
number as far as anyone can tell the
maximum lifespan of a human being is
about 125 years
no one has lived beyond 123 as far as we
know
um and very few have lived beyond about
110.
so um
and i believe we understand that but the
question then is what are the
interventions we can make and the
interventions the classic one is of
course to
improve repair mechanisms because if you
repair more
um you know obviously with like with
your car if you take it to the shop
every week and get everything repaired
that car will last not just 10 years or
20 years it could last 100 years
and so that's the idea on the other hand
if you start intervent intervening
you have the potential of all kinds of
unintended consequences and you also
have the problem that you're now going
to be allocating
a significant part of your metabolic
energy not to living and enjoying life
and doing all the kinds of things we do
but in repairing yourself
so one of the unintended concepts may be
that yes you can go on living beyond 125
but you're going to be a couch potato
i mean i just say that as a speculative
content yeah i mean i guess the counter
would be if you can externalize that
repair
where the energy is coming from you know
burning fuel where energy comes from now
right electricity the sun coal whatever
then that might be a way to counter that
argument yes so i should have said that
that's within the context that we don't
do anything
we don't sort of become
cyborgs or we don't sort of hook
ourselves up to something no so the
other possibility which is more radical
is what you say
is that
we intervene from the x externally
rather than internally
and you know we somehow supply that
energy or that mechanism that reverse
not doesn't reverse aging but um
which i think is less likely but in fact
um halts aging or slows it down and then
that is you know that's totally
speculative and it's but it's not
impossible to imagine
uh conceptually but again
one of the things that we've learned
those of us that have studied so-called
complex adaptive systems
is that
everything is connected with everything
else right
and that's what my book is about in fact
that everything is unified connected
with everything else which means that if
you fiddle with something over here
and try to mitigate something here you
may have unintended consequences over
there
and of course we're going through that
with the virus in a way i mean with the
with the pandemic i mean my god who
would believe that the the mutation of
some bloody little
uh virus in wuhan china
would end up having you know
giving rise to a shortage of flower in
the united states no football in
spain and so on and so forth things that
seemed totally disconnected from it
well the reason was they were always
connected in some very loose way right
and it has triggered that so
so it's just a cautionary statement and
i think we have to be much more careful
um rather than focusing on one aspect of
longevity but to see it systemically and
holistically
last thing i want to ask about is we've
talked about a lot of the different
systems that can be
explained and described
with these different
mechanisms and critiques and and
explorations that you write about in the
book are there currently systems
that are outside of that that we don't
yet understand whether it's i mean okay
the the universe very do we have to go
that high or are are there systems that
don't conform to this type of analysis
i don't know the answer to that david
um that's a very good question
it's uh you know
it's it's similar to the the sort of
more fundamental question what are the
limits to science and scientific
investigation right you know how their
boundaries
and i don't know with this because one
of the things is we've
you know i with my colleagues have taken
this kind of framework which started out
in sort of fundamental physics
i introduced it into fundamental biology
ecosystems ecology i then extended it to
cities and urbanization
and to socioeconomic systems i've now
we've just been completing work
extending it to companies and
corporations and so on we've done it for
universities
um and it's sort of i don't know the
answer uh frankly whether where the
boundaries are but you know it's part of
what science does we push the boundaries
and we're always looking for both
confirmation and regularities but also
exceptions and outliers and ones that
are in violation of these things um i do
want to say one thing that it was
interesting in what you said by saying
going to the universe i think one of the
most intriguing aspects
of working on these kinds of problems is
to recognize that
in a certain sense we understand the
universe
and the evolution of the universe from
the big bang and therefore the uh
the development of galaxies and then
eventually solar systems planets and so
on
better that we understand the messy
world that sits on this planet
like socioeconomic systems even the
weather i mean we're only coming now
to grips with questions of climate and
weather but socioeconomic systems we
don't really understand and so on and
that's what part of this work is is to
push that boundary and to see how far
you can go and and the last thing i want
to say about it that's very important
understanding the solar system for
example or understanding the universe
relies on physics and there the laws are
precise
and the laws that i'm talking about are
imprecise that is what we call coarse
grained they're very good at telling you
average quantities and something about
this the statistical distribution around
them and so on but going into individual
cases and into
details down at fine fine scale level
is
is where the challenge ultimately is
uh i want to remind the audience the
book is called scale the universal laws
of growth innovation sustainability and
many other things we've been speaking
with the book's author professor jeffrey
west such a pleasure having you on i
can't tell you how much i appreciate
your time
yes david thank you for having me and
thank you for your stimulating questions
i appreciate it